bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission qu'on serait comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite
le sommaire de votre émission football
le versailles s'est fait sortir au 7e
tour de la coupe de france les gars ayo
perdu sur leur terrain aux tirs au but
contre le blanc mesnil
tous les détails dans cette édition
gymnastique coup de projecteur sur le
club j'aime et l'empereur maurepas dans
ce magazine
entretien / heck émilie roy entraîneur
des équipes élite féminine chaîne morris
vice champion de france 2015 et camille
coudray championne de france au bar judo
les championnats de france juniors se
sont déroulées ce samedi dimanche au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus de 380 judokas venus de toute la
france ont participé à la compétition
et puis en fin d'émission tour d'horizon
des résultats sportifs du week-end dans
le département nous parlerons notamment
de handball féminin avec le match nul
des féminines de montier bretonneux
contre angoulême on commence ce magazine
par le 7e tour de la coupe de france de
football versailles qui évolue en dh
s'est incliné à domicile aux tirs au but
contre le blanc mesnil une équipe de
leur division les joueurs de la cité
royale ont pourtant largement dominé la
rencontre camille lambert pour les
images une défaite rageante versets qui
voulaient en blanc ce samedi tout mais
contre le blanc mesnil au 7e tour de la
coupe de france
dominateurs les versailles n'ont pas
réussi à trouver la faille malgré une
dizaine d'occasions
le score 0 0 ce manque de réalisme a
poussé les deux équipes à se départager
aux penaltys dans cette loterie les
joueurs de seine saint denis ont
remporté là
5 tirs au but à 4 on n'a pas su
concrétiser toutes les occasions qu'on a
pu en avoir au moins tu as de franches
en première mi temps notamment en
première mi temps on aurait pu plier le
match assez rapidement on a réalisé le
match qu'on souhaitait dans la
préparation du match maintenant
malheureusement en termes de
concrétisation des situations nombreuses
qu'on s'est procurées on a été on a été
faibles et ils malheureusement un match
on n'est pas notée sur un match on est
de noter sur le score donc là donc on
sort penalty tant pis pour nous on doit
servir de ce match là pour pouvoir
rebondir et et tirer les leçons de ce
match avec une victoire l'équipe de
versailles qui évolue en dh aurait pu
rencontrer mainvilliers une équipe de
dsr au 8e tour
un tirage au sort accessible qui laisse
des regrets au verset y est sorti de la
région parisienne on a fait un premier
tour national c'est intéressant c'est
bien mais on avait quand même l'ambition
d'aller plus loin
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
derrière quoi derrière il ya quelque
chose de sympa à faire et
malheureusement on a raté cette marche
donc on peut s'en prendre qu'à nous
mêmes après cette aventure en coupe de
france versailles devra se reconcentrer
dès ce dimanche sur le championnat les
joueurs de la cité royale sont pour
l'instant 2e du classement avec cinq
points de retard sur le leader les
mureaux versailles est donc éliminé de
cette 99e édition de la coupe de france
dans le département une seule équipe est
encore en lice pour le 8e tour de la
compétition
mantha russe a remporté son duel contre
les guyane et d'iracoubo sur le score de
4 buts à 0 grâce à des buts de luxe
masse en pouille dembélé
en revanche l'aventuré s'arrête pour
poissy les pisciacais qui évolue en cfa
se sont inclinés à surprise générale 1
but à 0 après prolongations extérieur
sur le terrain du club réunionnais
d'excelsior club de dh
on connaît déjà le programme du 8e
tourmente jouera le week-end du 5
décembre à domicile contre marck une
équipe de cfa2 après le football on
parle gymnastique
nous continuons nous continuons ce
magazine par un coup de projecteur sur
le club des encours maurepas qui compte
plus de 400 licenciés pour nous parler
de cette structure nous recevons sur ce
plateau émilie roy entraîneur des
équipes élite féminine camille coudray
championne de france au bar et vice
championne offrant son concours général
et ancien membre de l'équipe de france
et celle morris vice champion de france
2015 bonsoir nécessaire soit lors de ses
derniers championnats d'île de france en
mars dernier le club a décroché 8
médailles dont trois en or et 19 china
se sont qualifiés pour les championnats
de france
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
camille que le club n'est encore pas est
l'un des meilleurs clubs du département
cc d'île de france alors du département
en effet on se classe très bien après au
niveau l'île de france on est on est un
club assez bien placés dans nos
résultats on est assez bon on est on a
une équipe qui étendait dans les
dernière et cette année qui tourne au
top douce donc c'est les 12 meilleurs
clubs de france donc généralement les
essais bonnes mains c'est bon club
d'accord ml on cherche pas forcément à
être le meilleur club du département de
la région même si ça reste malgré tout
un objectif mais en fait ce qu'on
cherche c'est à apprendre la plus jolie
gym la gym la plus performante aux
enfants qu'on a entre les mains que ce
soit sur les masculins ou sur les
féminins et puis après le résultat c'est
le résultat et c'est vrai qu'à l'heure
actuelle on peut dire qu'on a beaucoup
de chance là dessus le travail paie
c'est le travail vraiment qui fait la
réussite de ce club depuis plusieurs
années je crois que c'est les gymnastes
qui sont mieux placés pour vous répondre
mais moi en tant qu'entraîneur
effectivement il ya d'autres paramètres
mais le
la qualité et la quantité du travail
reste et les deux maîtres mots
chen vous êtes d'accord avec emilie
c'est le travail qui paye tout à fait
gyms et de la répétition fin comme dans
beaucoup de sports mais je pense que la
gym a fortiori c'est vraiment de la
répétition de la répétition de même
élément de des scieries de musculation
d'étirement et donc en fait c'est
vraiment là l'abnégation et le fait de
s'entraîner jusqu'à 12 heures 15 heures
par semaine qui nous amène à des bons
résultats comme ça camille est ce que
quand vous arrivez vous dans une
compétition où vous craint vous
personnellement il même le club est ce
qu'on a on dit tout de suite il ça y est
il y à l encours maurepas qui est là ça
nous enlève les médailles alors moi
personnellement j'espère je pense pas
après on sentait pas non c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on ressent et à
personne vraiment qui craint que
quelqu'un sait c'est une ambiance pas du
tout dans ce style là après le club
d'elancourt n'a niveau féminin à prix
masculin je sais pas on est assez bien
placé au niveau de nos résultats mais de
là à nous craindre je pense pas emilie
est ce que ce club à toutes les
structures pour réussir effectivement on
peut dire qu'à l'heure actuelle on a une
bonne structure on a une salle
spécifique il ya quand même des petits
clubs qui eux ont besoin de monter leur
matériel à chaque séance c'est pas notre
cas on a une on a une salle qui équipés
correctement des six agrès pour les
masculins des quatre agrès pour les
féminines plus trampoline une fausse ça
nous a permis aujourd'hui d'arriver à ce
niveau là c'est évident mais les normes
de la fédération internationale évoluant
chaque année vraiment très régulièrement
les infrastructures supplémentaires
là l'heure actuelle on souffre
cruellement d'un
à nouveau praticable qui a été qui a été
modifié par la fédération internationale
est arrivée sur des compétitions
nationales ou cse praticable là on est
très très embêté parce que nos gymnastes
ne sont pas entraînés sur celui ci et ça
leur pose beaucoup de problèmes
techniques
chen est ce qu'il ya des jeunes qui
viennent dans le club des encours
maurepas voilà tout simplement pas sa
réputation pour progresser oui c'est
certain ça c'est ils viennent pas
forcément du secteur il y en a qui
viennent de très loin du fin fond du
78ème parce que enfin et même parfois au
delà du 70 vite parce que c'est un club
comme il fonctionne très bien
il n'a pas énormément dans 78 qui
fonctionne aussi bien du coup c'est
vraiment un pôle d'attraction au terme
jimmy quoi c'est bien chez les gaffes
comme chez les gamins chez les garçons
comme chez les filles de l'accord emilie
abbaoui oui effectivement à l'heure
actuelle sans dire de bêtises je pense
que le
on a un tiers de nos adhérents un tiers
de l'encours toi un tiers de maurepas
gien et un tiers de communes extérieures
et on n'a pas effectivement on reçoit
énormément d'enfants du soixante dix
huit mais on en a même qui traverse
l'île de france pour s'entraîner chez
nous je prends pour exemple une donnée
meilleurs gymnastes jade pâtissons qui
habite dans 77 près de disneyland et qui
met une heure trente quand ça roule pour
juste venir s'entraîner à chez nous
parce que la qualité du travail
l'ambiance font que aujourd'hui on a
envie de nous rejoindre la structure
propose également une politique de
formation pour les plus jeunes
en écoute justement eric matra
responsable technique du gm et la femme
et la jeune flavie d'enfer championne de
france en équipe on a une politique de
formation à plusieurs niveaux on a
d'abord été orientés vers les loisirs
l'objectif c'est leur faire découvrir la
gymnastique de leur faire aimer ce sport
et à terme si elles ont des aptitudes de
les orienter dans les groupes qui
correspondent à leur niveau pour
terminer dans les groupes de
performances des groupes objectif
nationale et
championnat de france un nouvelle équipe
l'objectif aussi c'est de développer le
haut niveau avec l'ouverture d'une
section dans les années futures et les
faire intégrer les pôles espoirs et plus
tard l'équipe de france de gymnastique
et fait qu'il fasse sa saison qui va
rater
il faut que je suis plus fort que toi tu
vas réussir
emilie on remarque dans cette interview
d'eric m'a trahi a une véritable envie
de pousser les jeunes vraiment au plus
haut niveau
effectivement parfois ça à la fin oui ça
peut être le plus haut niveau c'est
surtout de développer leur potentiel au
maximum potentiel qui est propre à
chacun mais parfois effectivement ça
peut aller jusqu'au niveau en tout cas
on essaye de suivre le plan de détection
de la fédération pour permettre à chaque
jeune âge s'ils le souhaitent
d'envisager une carrière de haut niveau
oui mais à quel âge on peut s'inscrire 1
accueille les enfants dès 2 ans voilà
sur des cours de baby gym je vous
rassure donc c'est de la motricité ce
sont des parcours de motricité et puis
dès l'âge de 6 ans on commence un petit
peu a détecté des des qualités
spécifiques une envie particulière et
comme l'a dit rick matra dans le
reportage à ce moment là on les oriente
vers des groupes soit vers les masculins
soit vers les féminines pour pourra
prendre un petit peu plus à faire de la
gymnastique
et vous qu'avez vous avez commencé à
quel âge moi j'ai commencé à 9 ans
d'abord oui ok j'ai commencé un peu plus
tard je faisais pas jim au début et j'ai
essayé la gym et comment gère-t-on les
futurs les futurs talents comment
comment les préserve à ce qu'il faut les
faire travailler très dur ou est-ce
qu'il faut également les gérer au niveau
tout ce qui est croissance etc
c'est une somme un petit peu tout ça
mais avant toute chose avant de parler
de 2,2 au niveau de travail il faut leur
faire aimer la gym ça reste la priorité
parce que s'il n'aime pas vraiment ça
ils le font pour nous pour leurs parents
on n'arrivera pas en tirer le meilleur
donc dès lors qu'on sent qu'ils ont
vraiment comme on dit dans notre jargon
accroché développé une passion pour la
gymnastique et qu'on sent qu'ils
prennent du plaisir à l'entraînement à
ce moment là on peut augmenter la
quantité de travail et augmenter notre
niveau d'exigence mais s'il n'ya pas le
plaisir d'être dans la salle le plaisir
d'être ex entraîneur et leur la
gymnastique
ça prendra pas
shane en marque le club est très
familiale est-ce que vous comme vous
c'est tj menace plutôt confirmé avec amy
est ce que vous vous donnez des conseils
aux plus jeunes est ce que vous les
prenez un peu sous votre aile pour
justement faire progresser le club
oui très souvent en fait on s'entraîne
voyez des horaires qui sont un peu
différents mais globalement on tombe
toujours sur des échelles horaires qui
correspondent avec les petits et donc ça
arrive très souvent que on s'entraîne ou
même à gré en même temps que du coup là
on leur prodigue nos conseils et en tant
que gymnase parce que l'entraîneur il
est sorti d'âge il nous faut forcément
y'a pas forcément toujours les conseils
donc nous on donne des bons conseils et
à la fois enfin je trouvais ça
intéressant l'esprit familial parce que
c'est peut-être ce qui explique aussi la
fin la réussite du club c'est que c'est
lui 0,7 en tout cas de je pense que
c'est définitivement une des recettes
parce que on n'est pas là juste pour la
compétition on est là aussi pour voir
nos amis on s'entend bien on est content
d'aller à la gym et la fois en
compétition on est on est une équipe
qu'on ait limite une famille
contrairement à deux équipes qui ont des
étrangers qui viennent et qui qui ne
connaissent absolument pas les gens qui
sont dans leur équipe et donc nous ça
crée une certaine cohésion et un esprit
de famille s'est plaint il ya le côté
également travail aussi lit à côté
familial mais également le côté travail
les filles travaillent entre 15 et 18
heures par semaine en bref il ya une
émulation
c'est ce qui permet de tenir aussi je
pense que avec tendeur de gym par
semaine
si on n'avait pas une bonne ambiance et
si on avait passé des copains pour nous
pousser
je pense que ce serait difficile
d'inform camille est ce que vous sentez
qu'il ya des jeunes du club qui peuvent
prétendre aller aux jeux olympiques ou
intégrer l'équipe de france en trucs là
bas mon moi je trouve qu'il ya des
petites qui sont bien après faut voir la
croissance comment ça va se passer
comment elles vont évoluer dans la gym
aussi on peut pas dire tout de suite oui
elle ou celle ci valent en équipe de
france ou voire faux faut tester tout et
puis je pense qu'il ya des bons potes de
sel dans notre club
amy est ce que le club peut encore
progresser et dans quels domaines il
doit progresser encore mais on va tout
faire pour progresser ça c'est sûr en
on va chercher chez les féminines à se
maintenir dans le top 12 cette année à
avoir encore des médailles en individuel
chez les garçons je suppose qu'ils vont
encore chercher à briguer un podium à
l'échelle nationale ça c'est sûr donc on
va tous chaque niveau que ce soit les
bénévoles du club les parents des gym
nous les entraîneurs et puis les
gymnastes avant tout s'investir pour
progresser il faut aussi que les
financements nous suivent
voilà c'est pas toujours facile d'avoir
des financements à la hauteur de nos
besoins que ce soit sur les partenaires
publics comme les partenaires privés
donc on va essayer de développer aussi
davantage ce secteur là merci à vous
tous trois d'être passé sur ce plateau
on vous souhaite bonne continuation avec
votre club et on vous souhaite également
de ramener plein de médailles à saint
quentin en yvelines
on passe à présent au judo les
championnats de france de judo était
organisée ce week-end au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
une première dans l'enceinte sportive
plus de 380 judokas venus de toute la
france ont participé à la compétition
le montage est signée as roma russe
finit des kimonos des ceintures rouges
et noirs le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a revêtu ses
habits de judokas ce week-end les
championnats de france par équipes de
club junior et la coupe de france
individuel junior était programmée dans
l'enceinte sportive devilloise une
grande première
ça c'est impressionnant mais la pièce
est grande vigueur
mais la pièce quand on rentre dedans
comme un petit peu partout et ouais
franchement c'est beau au total plus de
380 judokas venus de toute la france ont
participé à la compétition un record
pour le département
on peut dire que c'est un événement
exceptionnel puisque c'est une première
de les faire une compétition de judo
dans un vélodrome
d'autant plus que ce vélodrome nationale
a plein de possibilités de faire des
événements autre colonne d'eau donc on
est un peu la première discipline à
faire cette manifestation sportive
ça va donner des idées les autres
disciplines dans les travées du
vélodrome une dizaine d'anciens judokas
professionnel a fait le déplacement pour
évaluer le niveau des champions de
demain une qualité qualités physiques et
techniques est tout à fait indiscutable
donc de toutes façons on n'arrive pas au
niveau national dans une compétition que
ce soir junior ou dans n'importe quelle
catégorie sans avoir un minimum de deux
compétences et là manifestement elle est
là après les juniors le vélodrome est
candidat pour accueillir les
championnats de france seniors en 2016
un certain teddy riner pourrait alors
foulé les tatamis de saint quentin en
yvelines après championnats de france
juniors nous passons une autre
compétition qui devrait ravir les
amateurs de judo le but vide au club de
trappes organise ce week-end la 23e
édition de son tournoi international de
judo pour nous parler de la compétition
nous recevons sur ce plateau michel
barbier le président du club ainsi que à
un autre michel michel roux le
vice-président bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
il ya beaucoup de judo en ce moment à
saint quentin limite c'est positif pour
votre discipline
oui ça marche bien et suite aux
championnats du monde était quand même
assez riche pour les français je pense
que les enfants surtout nous dans le
club on a une bonne quantité d'enfants
de petites qu'on les prend à partir de 4
ans et j'aime ça y sont
100 demandeurs michel roux auzits et oui
j'étais de france est effectivement
c'était une très belle manifestation
le vélodrome permet de d'accueillir ce
genre de choses ce genre de compétition
vraiment dans d'excellentes conditions
après nous avons eu quelques
démonstrations de pistard qui a animé un
petit peu de lorie kane mais globalement
c'est vraiment une très belle très belle
compétition et elle est vraiment une
réussite pour l'ensemble des bénévoles
qui ont beaucoup participé et puis bien
entendu des la fédération française de
judo qui a mis beaucoup de moyens pour
réussir mais qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé du niveau de la compétition or le
niveau est très haut très haut
la lyre le temps du oui assure puisque
maintenant il ya pratiquement tous les
sports et tue tous les pôles espoirs
sont dans cette dans cette compétition
donc on a le plus haut niveau français
au volant tournoi national de trappes
il est programmé ce week end donc à
trappes
combien de judokas sont attendus pour la
compétition alors combien nous avons
donc 1000 mais je le cas un peu plus de
1000 jeunes et cad inscrits pour
l'instant d'autres encore s'inscrivent
donc là aussi c'est une belle
manifestation la seule chose c'est que
les conditions actuelles enfin les
récents événements ont réduit un petit
peu la participation des étrangers et de
mon beaucoup ne s'est pratiquement un
championnat national laquelle quelques
individuels et rongeurs mais vraiment
très peu et quels sont les étrangers du
cou qui vont venir à pour la compétition
michel 90 et plus michel roux parce que
c'est plus mashaal qui ce qu'on fait il
y à quelques belges de hollandais mais
vraiment très très peu pour ça que cette
année malheureusement ce sera pas les
mêmes fait que
des années précédentes et encore je ne
sais pas excuse moi si les baies gens
pourront venir parce que apparemment en
belgique ils ont plus le droit de sortir
pour l'instant du territoire c'est un
avantage
quant à et aux perquisitions qui est en
belgique et autres dont je ne sais pas
si on les aura sur le tournoi on verra
ça ce week-end malheureusement est ce
qu'il y a des jeunes à surveiller en
particulier les jeunes à fort potentiel
michel roux alors plutôt d'accord pour
dire quand même que ce tournoi donc est
ouvert à pratiquement toute la france sa
et la champagne champagne ardenne pas de
calais bourgogne charente serra pour
c'est vraiment un rassemblement de
national concernant le le club de
trappes à il y a trois quatre jeunes
important paquet qui ont un niveau un
bon niveau et bien entendu notre show
ehpad rage au népal rats qui a été
champion d'île de france l'année
dernière et qui est actuellement
sport-études de breaking on compte un
peu sur lui pour pouvoir représenter
dignement les couleurs de trappeurs et
donc il y aura des spectacles toute
façon il y aura du spectacle est en
général la particularité de ce tournoi
c'est que ça se passe dans des bonnes
conditions sereines 1 2 rennes et ce qui
n'empêche pas quand même eu des bagarres
à seat ans michel barbier c'est la 23ème
édition est ce que vous sentez que ce
tournoi à prendre l'ampleur au fur et à
mesure des années ou est-ce qu'on vous
en parle régulièrement ou dans le
courant de l'année non mais je sais que
le tournoi est très très attendu ça on
le ressent tous les ans le rendez vous
concocte les gens pour qu'ils s'en vont
nous disent à l'année prochaine ont dit
oui mais bon tous les ans on se dit 20
on s'est quand même une grosse
organisation c'est quand même un travail
bien qu'on soit habitué mais bon faut
toujours se remettre en question et mais
c'est vrai que c'est un tournoi qui est
très attendu c'est le plus gros tournois
de la région
je pense de la région ile-de-france
saint-james je me trompe pas c'est plus
gros tournoi c'est un tournoi live comme
l'appelle nathan noah labellisé donc ça
compte pour les pour le passage des
ceintures pour les points et autres et
c'est un tournoi qui est très attendu
michel roux est ce que le public pourra
assister à la manifestation
oui oui bien sûr au contraire je dirais
que c'est un c'est une belle compétition
dans un gymnase vraiment exceptionnel le
gymnase sous le maillet a une c'est une
structure agréable plus + 2 - plus ou
moins grande que le vélodrome et qui est
beaucoup plus chaleureux il ya vraiment
il ya des couleurs et à c'est vraiment
un gymnase que j'apprécie
particulièrement pour ce qui concerne
les jeunes de trappes donc en fait il y
à jo salueront il y a ephraïm ring dit
et puis donc et adil hadi la jolie et
donc notre je vais jouer
les mots manquent et devrait qui devrait
pouvoir sortir leur épingle du jeu du
beau monde
du baume mercier voulais le passer sur
ce plateau bon courage pour
l'organisation de cette compétition je
pense que vous allez pas beaucoup dormir
sur les sur les prochains jours on en
passe maintenant au handball au national
une montigny-le-bretonneux n'a pas
réussi à s'imposer ce samedi à domicile
les joueuses coachée par philippe
étrange ont concédé le match nul 32 à 30
2 après avoir mené au score pendant
toute la partie contre angoulême
romain ospina pour le montage
une fin de match qui risque de coûter
cher à montigny-le-bretonneux promu
cette année en national coulée verte et
noire en considère le nul 32 à 32 sur
leur terrain contre angoulême dans les
ultimes secondes de la rencontre
les immortels ont pourtant mené pendant
toute la partie en compter jusqu'à six
buts d'avancé en seconde période des
regrets au final beaucoup de regrets la
sueur sur le match nul on prend un point
donc ça c'est bien sur le plan comptable
maintenant beaucoup de regrets parce
qu'on était toujours devant et on prend
un but à cinq secondes de la fin des
moments de flottement notamment en
défense au moins sur quinze minutes de
jeu ça a été trois minutes par ci des
minutes par là à divers moments en
première mi temps comme en deuxième
une brève communication est souvent
s'est emballée assez rapidement sur les
phases de jeu et on a perdu pied voilà
qu'on n'a pas réussi à garder à
maintenir cet écart et c'est ce qui nous
a valu le match nul ce soir après cette
rencontre les joueuses de beauty votre
le pointe à la 8e place du classement
après huit journées le maintien
l'objectif annoncé par le club est donc
toujours envisageable en vise le
maintien en mer entre la 6e et la 9e
place ça c'est sûr on vise le maintien
et je pense que ce match là nous prouve
qu'on peut assurer le maintien et
j'espère ça nous d'être toujours un peu
agressive
défense a haussé le niveau tout le temps
en fait donc ça va être rude mais on le
savait déjà
en signant pour la l1 prochain match
pour les féminines de boutiers brut le
samedi 28 novembre à 20h30 contrôlé à
domicile
c'est officiel après deux mois de
fermeture pour travaux les activités du
boxing club de la verrière ont repris au
gymnase du bois de l'étang depuis début
novembre
la salle est désormais plus spacieuse un
mur a été cassée pour doubler la
superficie l'antre des boxeurs very roi
fait désormais 220 m² au lieu de 110 un
vrai plus pour les 62 licenciés du club
on écoute le responsable à sanaa au riz
et le jeune boxeur jordan duick en
termes de changements en a une plus
grande salle on a des vestiaires propres
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant dans
l'ancien gymnase avant qu'ils soient
rénovés et puis voilà quoi donc
oncle accueillir beaucoup plus de monde
si on sent ça ne me il y aura plus de
gens concession donc les gens
compétition seront plus d'effectifs ça
sera un peu mieux pour développer les
champions et plus de championnat sera
plus de classement donc ça sera bien la
salle n'est pas encore complète un
deuxième risque de waters 2 1 2e ring
devrait être installée à côté du premier
dans les prochaines semaines
on passe aux autres résultats du
week-end en rugby plaisir qui est
descendue cette année en fédérale 2 a
perdu son premier match de la saison les
isérois se sont inclinés de justesse 18
à 16 contre aures orangis maisons
laffitte de son côté s'est incliné 13 à
11 contre marcq en baroeul au classement
plaisir aux descendra à la deuxième
place redescend un deuxième place le
championnat et maintenant dominé par ris
orangis maisons laffitte reste bon
dernier du classement de cette poule une
sommes toujours en fédérale 3 de rugby
mais cette fois ci dans la poule de
versailles s'est lourdement incliné à
l'extérieur sur le terrain d'anthony et
versailles ont été battus dans tous les
secteurs de jeu comme le score l'indiqué
au niveau du classement les yvelinois
descendent à l'avant dernière place avec
sept points engrangés depuis le début de
la saison à deux petites unités de la
dernière place on passe au handball
nouvelle défaite pour le chesnais les
libinois se sont lourdement inclinés à
domicile contre rennes lors de la 7e
journée du championnat de nationale 2
score final 32 à 22 au classement les
chiliens sont toujours derniers du
championnat avec six défaites en sept
matches
la défense a déjà encaissé 100 90 buts
depuis le début de la saison on termine
ce magazine par un rendez-vous rugby le
sky rugby reçoit clermont ce week-end
pour le compte de la 6e journée du
championnat de promotion d'honneur
ce match est considéré comme le choc de
cette poule saint quentin en yvelines
est actuellement deuxième avec cinq
victoires en cinq matches et clairement
pointe à la première place avec 22
points
si vous voulez encourager encourager le
sky rendez-vous stade du bout des clos
dimanche à 15 heures c'est la fin de
cette fuite sport merci d'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve jeudi prochain pour le
talk sport si on parlait sport très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78